c'est un dispositif d'intelligence
énergétique pour recharger un véhicule
électrique une station composé de 70 m²
de panneaux solaires et de deux
batteries de voitures destinées au
stockage un système classique de
rechargement alimenté par une production
d'énergie innovante alors à l'intérieur
ce conteneur réalisé par bouygues
énergie des services vous avez retrouvé
en fait deux batteries de kangoo usagers
qui si on était vraiment été on vous
voit elles sont dans leurs étagères et
utilisation automobile et vous trouvez
de l'électronique de puissance pour une
fête exploiter ses batteries et
convertir de l'énergie de manière à
pouvoir recharger le véhicule par ce
biais la voiture est chargé directement
par le soleil d'un côté et par l'énergie
du soleil stockée dans les batteries de
seconde vie pour assurer la recherche du
véhicule
ils sont cinq collaborateurs du
technocentre de guyancourt a piloté le
développement de ce projet une
infrastructure d'apprentissage de
recherche destiné à terme à la
commercialisation uniquement dans les
entreprises une étape dans la poursuite
du développement du véhicule électrique
la stratégie globale de renault c'est
d'amener cette technologie électrique au
plus grand nombre et donc au coût le
plus abordable pour voir la massifier et
contribuer au réseau à la résolution des
problèmes de la planète
aujourd'hui finalement avec les
autonomie de 300 km que vous avez sur la
zoé derrière moi et puis 390 sur la
nouvelle version de zoé 3 qu'on va
commercialiser à la rentrée on a
vraiment je dirais résolus complètement
ce problème là pour tous les usages du
quotidien la renault zoé le véhicule le
plus commercialisé en europe avec
environ quarante mille unités vendues en
2018 dont dix-huit mille en france